hi in this video we are going to talk
about an important
electrophysiological property of neuron
known as the input resistance you might
have heard about this term but you are
not so familiar with it and you don't
understand it so at the end of this
video this particular term would be
completely clear so it's the intrinsic
property of the neuron so what does
intrinsic property means that means it
is something unique to every neuron so
one does input resistance tells us so
input resistance tells us about the
excitability of the neuron that's how
much the neuron can get excitable when
you inject a current so whenever we
inject a current we see if the current
is actually beyond the threshold we
would see a all-or-none phenomena which
is the action potential right now this
action potential is nothing but a
voltage change or Delta changing the
voltage and we know from Ohm's law that
voltage is proportional to current and
you can remove that and you can say V
equal to IR and in this case its input
resistance so it's R in so input
resistance is nothing but the ratio of
voltage by current so this current you
are actually injecting this current and
the voltage deflection is basically
recorded by you and the ratio of the two
is known as the input resistance now we
very often compare a new one to be
actually a RC circuit right we very much
compare the neuron to be an RC circuit
so here we have a capacitor component
and we have a resistor component now
whenever we inject some amount of
current in this circuit first
current is used to charge the capacitor
and then it is flowing through the
resistor so let's see let's try an
experiment so in this experiment we are
going to inject some current and we are
going to look at the voltage responses
and in this particular case we are going
to inject some negative current so let's
say so we are going to inject some
negative current in a stepwise fashion
and this step increment is pretty much
constant and what would happen this
initial current it is a small magnitude
of current so it would be essentially
charging the capacitor and when we stop
the current it would be discharging the
capacitor so we have a increase followed
by reaching a steady-state and then
there is a discharging phase then
eventually the magnitude would grow and
reach a plateau
so for each injected current range we
are getting a voltage deflection so we
are inputting some current for each
current change we are also getting a
change in the voltage and the ratio of
this voltage versus current is known as
input resistance now at a particular
defined voltage or at a particularly
defined input current we can calculate
the input resistance and thereby plot a
graph of input resistance right now the
question is what does this input
resistance tells us and at a empirical
level or at a molecular level what does
input resistance mean so let's look at
that so here is a neuron and let us
imagine this is we are calling your own
one and here there is another neuron we
are calling this as neuron two okay now
neuron one has a very high input
resistance and neuron two has small
input resistance so what is different in
between these two neurons
so whenever we have high input
resistance that means this neuron is
more this means this neuron is more
excitable and this neuron the neuron too
is less excitable compared to the neuron
one okay so then what does that mean in
terms of similar level in
electrophysiological level that means
you give a small current very small
current and you are able to get a large
voltage deflection but here upon giving
a small current you are getting only a
small voltage deflection or even getting
in order to achieve the same amount of
voltage deflection what we have gone got
earlier we have to really give a very
high current so input current is
different so this particular neuron the
first neuron is way more excitable that
means a small change in current can give
rise to a huge change in the voltage and
why it is so because the change of the
voltage and the change of the current is
actually or input resistance and now
input resistance is a constant term so
if there is a sort of like small change
in the voltage in or a small change in
the current in order to make it constant
the change in the voltage would be big
right now what we are going to try to
understand that at a cellular level what
is different so let us look at the axons
or the dendrites of these cells so when
there is a very high input resistance
that means the conductor or the
transporters or the ion channels that
are present are actually in a closed
configuration that means not too much
ions are leaking outside and that is why
it is like a seed hose pipe and water
can nicely flow inside it so charge can
flow nicely across these neurons but in
this situation of neuron two we would
predict that
there are a lot of channels which are in
an open configuration and that is why a
lot of the League of charges are
happening as a result it is very
difficult to excite this mingle we have
to increase our injectable current to
get a same amount of voltage deflection
and this is the overall picture about
input resistance and how what we can
understand from input resistance so I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
this video click on thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you